yeah welcome to this video five-minute
game and just as you try to get some
interesting play going with the Sicilian
you get hit by c3 again so if you
transpose too yeah we stay within within
the French kind of territory okay then I
have some old line that i played years
ago and that I always like to black okay
yeah 94 is the more common move and but
he plays queen d 4 which is probably
better get this whole way of playing is
some very solid for white of course but
I cannot expect to to get much fun in
this kind of position but it's also not
terribly dangerous if black doesn't
commit some some big error b3 is really
strange if you need to do that and then
something's wrong it just weakens
squares and doesn't do much maybe you
need to do that no ok so castles cannot
go without that so just rookie adium
with the idea Bishop c5
okay Bishop c5 he goes to wear f4 maybe
I need to activate pizza's here let's
flick this in control g5 so that 95 or
stuff like that it's no option I will
play a Bishop c5 anyway and then have a
really good Bishop putting some pressure
here on f 2 and so on so on okay a form
basically telling me okay you cannot
take on b3 yeah maybe I really cannot
but it's not a big deal yeah all this
just weakens wide I don't know the best
that he can achieve in this position is
now to play c4 and get rid of the seats
you so weakness on c3 yeah something
like that so let's improve the position
further Bishop p6 attacking and after
rookie form this queen is trapped yeah
quite a sudden end I think it that
wasn't happening much really if it
doesn't doesn't give me the queen but he
was a bit on the wrong track it's really
not good to move the queenside pawns
just better to to keep them on be two
and A two and so on he probably am yeah
rookie one probably I mean I really
prefer black already because the Queen
side is so weak but it shouldn't be a
shouldn't be so terrible can play rook
c8 for example or a 5 is also good if
white needs to play be five and maybe he
needs to then I've got c5 I simply have
a bishop and the bishop is better than
in this kind of open position especially
when you attack f2 yeah thanks for
watching this rather quick game